uh all right let me make a
recommendation to you today I want to
recommend the documentary to you small
is beautiful a tiny house documentary
this is a documentary that is sort of
about the tiny house movement and the
movement towards building these really
small houses uh but it is also about
some of the stories of individual people
in the film their backstory and what
motivated them to seek this sort of
smaller footprint uh lifestyle or our
way of living the documentary is really
really well done I find the entire tiny
house movement fascinating I don't know
that I could do it myself like a hundred
and twenty square foot home that you
trailer around with a truck I don't know
if I could do it I mean it is very
appealing in terms of having total
mobility in being able to move around
and and basically drive your house
wherever you want and park it and have
it there I totally get that but a
hundred and twenty square feet mean that
that's smaller than many hotel rooms I
mean I note 120 sounds really small but
there are places that have that small
the hotel room I don't know that I could
do it i add about Rachel do you think
that you'd be comfortable living full
time in a hundred and twenty square foot
house absolutely not just because of
claustrophobia however I definitely
appreciate the environmental impact of
tiny houses yeah no doubt about it and
and again the mobility is appealing I
like that that idea when you have an
apartment lease or own a condo or a
house uh you're not mobile in the way
that you would be if you could just
drive your house around and and so that
is a really interesting component to me
the documentary is fascinating we are
talking about small is beautiful a tiny
house documentary and you can get a list
of all of my recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each CarShare member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David